avant d'être coiffeuse
je voulais être coiffeuse je devais être
fait pour ça
c'est formidable vous savez changer le
visage des gens ça peut changer leur vie
on voit arriver des petites jeunes
filles on sent qu'elles sont pas bien
dans leur peau
elles se sentent femme pour la première
fois ils se sentent différentes elle se
trouve pèle
je m'appelle clément et bus et jennifer
ont dit jennyfer ces anglais et qu'est
ce que vous faites dans ma vie je suis
professeur de philosophie c'est pas un
truc d'intello la philosophie l'ispa de
la masturbation intellectuelle
c'est un sport de combat c'est la
meilleure façon de passer chez manipuler
sais pas ce que ça raconte mais c'est
avec du nifff harnist franchement je
vois pas qui c'est oui pas qui c'est
jennifer aniston mais dans quel monde
vivez clément toute façon je suis sûr
qu'on a pas les mêmes goûts pas du tout
comment tu expliques qu'un homme qui
s'est tellement de choses c'est plus
rien et qu'on parle du sentiment qu'est
ce qui se passe pourquoi tu dis ça
j'espère juste que tu m'as pas trop
menti